they're upping the gas lighting in the
trolling making it much much
worse they have a new theory
on how we can protect ourselves from the
coronavirus
you remember initially fauchi told us
masks don't work
don't wear masks the surgeon general
said do not wear masks people stop
buying them
eric swalwell he is me
he is you we are him eric swalwell
former future president
he came and said don't wear masks then
all those guys changed their mind they
said no you have to wear masks all the
time and if you don't you're going to
kill people
and when fauci was asked about his
change of heart he said oh well it's
because
i i was making a political decision i
wanted the masks for special people and
i didn't want you plebes to have the
mask so i told you not to wear them so i
lied to you but now listen to me now
and you got to wear it it's very
important but then you look and whenever
fauci is photographed in private
you know even if he's around people but
he doesn't think the cameras are on he
doesn't have the mask on
uh so very difficult to take him
seriously well now he's got a new he's
got
he's got a new theory the whole left
right not just about you but the entire
left has this new theory you should wear
two masks new york times two masks
are the new masks double masking is a
sensible and easy way to lower your risk
when you have to spend more time around
others in a taxi on a train or a plane
or at an inauguration
so they we have seen
time and time and time again that the
masks
seem to be a little less effective than
we were told they were
we we've seen studies to this effect
that have come out and said the masks
don't do very much
we've had major health officials
epidemiologists from colombia and fauci
himself come out and say
the masks don't do very much we just
know the way the masks are implemented
we're touching our faces people aren't
wearing them right
they're not doing much as fauci said
they make people feel good but they
don't accomplish a lot
so what does the new york times do do
they do they do they
finally admit to us do they let the mask
slip to use an
app metaphor and say okay yeah you got
us it was just kind of
whatever it's bs but we're making you do
it no
they look at us and they say hey yeah
where to
yeah where to i know we told you 15 days
to slow the spread
11 months ago yeah no just 15 more days
in the masks they're really
you know maybe we're three put them on
wear the mask say what we want you to
say
do what we want you to do i i made this
point uh
maybe a month or two ago no i guess it
was earlier than that during the the
virus
as it was really surging and everyone
was taking it very very seriously
i said what they're doing to you with
the masks is
is basically saying put this donut on
your head
right because the argument with the
masks was okay maybe they don't work
maybe they don't do very much but it
can't hurt
or maybe it can hurt a little bit if you
don't wear them correctly it actually
can increase the spread but
yeah and your certain masks but it won't
hurt that much just just do it come on
it's not a big deal
it's not a big deal just wear the masks
and they could make the same argument
say look hey
i know that this donut it's probably not
going to do very much
or whatever but uh look it will it'll
make everyone feel better
dr fauci wants you to do it um joe biden
wants you to do it
just put the donut on your head and then
uh jump up jump up and down on one on
one foot i know look it might maybe it
won't help but just do it
just do it it's all about
the imposition it's not about the thing
itself
when they tell you don't wear masks and
when they tell you do wear masks and
when they now tell you to wear two masks
none of that is about the masks it's
about the imposition it's about your
submission it's about you doing what
they say to do
when they come come on television and
they say hey
before you make your argument say what
we want you to say
no i know your argument is going to
address that say it use the exact words
that i want you to say say it
say it do it do it
[Music]
you